[Music]
should we talk about covid what do you
think yeah let's do it dude now's the
time now's the time all right
so so wait wait wait i got a text from
tim
it's two coved tests you're texting me
in soccer i think we can say that yeah
yeah and it's two it's two kova tests
and it's like they're both like clear
redlined
and you're like i mean you didn't say
[ __ ] but you were just like [ __ ] like
this this happened
here we go what was the first like walk
me through it like you just woke up one
morning i was like i just don't feel
right or what happened yeah i'll walk
you through it so this is about two
and a half weeks ago now i want to say
something like that and
it was if if i look back as you know
i've been very very careful
so careful
began tracking kovid and end of january
beginning of february 2020
put up a blog post which was very
moderate super moderate and
ultimately you know
in the subsequent weeks encouraged south
by southwest to cancel
and
uh was kind of dragged over the coals at
the time and then of course kovid turned
into what kova turned into
and
have been have been very careful uh not
because i assume that it is
instantaneous death that is not what i
assume but because i have pre-existing
respiratory issues
very well established respiratory issues
and
there were a lot of unknowns there
continue to be a lot of unknowns related
to covet 19 and
i wanted to delay
getting it as long as possible
so
and and
looking at the lifestyle calculus it was
very easy for me to mitigate risk
without making huge sacrifices so i saw
a lot of potential upside and very
limited downside to taking certain
precautions
i ended up going to f1 so formula one in
austin where
at least in the in the paddock everyone
had been
i believe both vaccinated and tested
negative with a pcr test within 48 or 72
hours
where i think i contracted it because
there are so few
options because i've been so careful
there are so few options
where i would have been exposed what i
think happened is i succumbed to social
pressure and the way it happened
is i had uh i had taken a car by myself
to and from
uh
circuit of the americas from coda
each day
and then on the last day getting back i
had not
i had made some mistake and there was a
snafu with transportation and so i ended
up getting
kind of directed to a location to
transportation which i assumed meant i
would be able to get a one-on-one ride
back to the city since trying to find
parking is just impossible i mean there
were 400 000 people there over three
days
so
i i end up in a golf cart driven
like a half a mile to this point ever
it's complete pandemonium right like
everyone is trying to leave coda at the
same time
and i get directed to this van and it's
like there's your ride now i had taken a
van
to the event that day but i was
one of three people on the van and we
spaced out and so on
and i also had a mask
on the way back
i opened the door of the van and it's
packed right it's like a 12-seater with
12 people or 11 people so that i could
fit in and they're like okay yeah hop on
in we're headed downtown and i was like
oh
[ __ ]
i don't want to do this
but at least where i was everyone was
tested
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever and then i got in and i sat
down and it's like there was this one
like model chick vaping in the [ __ ]
van i mean it was terrible and i'm just
sitting there like reading my kindle i'm
like if i'm going to get [ __ ] coveted
it's going to be right now here and then
about five days later
started feeling very very congested and
began to develop a really severe
headache
and i attributed it to allergies in
austin because austin has really really
bad allergies you have cedar or juniper
ash you have ragweed you have all sorts
of allergens that cause really severe
reactions in people
so i just assumed it was allergies and
then
i was getting ready
to pack to get on a flight to go to new
orleans for a friend's 50th birthday and
halloween
and we were by by basically my request
everyone was going to be pcr tested when
they landed
and we had my girlfriend and i buy next
kits at home so we had abbott
manufactured rapid antigen tests at home
and
i i was feeling congested and so she
very wisely suggested
well before we get on the plane and pack
and do all the stuff why don't you take
one before we go and i did
just as a formality right kept packing
da da da da da da came back and i'm like
oh [ __ ] that looks positive oh [ __ ] and
i don't know what the accuracy
there are different ways to assess these
tests but let's just say that it's
85 percent
accurate and peter t could give you a
much better description right well i
think it's one of those things when it's
it's if it has a positive it's more
likely to be positive it but it could
miss you know what i'm talking about
like there's right i do but also if you
just take two tests or three tests right
right you can you can get the likelihood
of two false positives down to say less
than five percent so let me ask you a
question one thing i'm always curious
about these things because we've all
done these at home or at least a few of
us have they're listening how quickly
did that other line show up i always
wondered
within five minutes it showed up so
quickly oh so it wasn't like because i
was like wait 15 minutes and i'm always
waiting okay
it popped up really quickly
and then did the second test and it
popped up really quickly and i was like
well this looks like a positive and
at that point
went immediately into
action mode
i didn't
panic
at that point i'm very good in christ's
crisis or i should say
and some people listening might say well
that's not a crisis well if you knew my
history and you knew some of the
outcomes that i've seen and the doctors
i've interacted with you wouldn't be as
cavalier but what is action mode for you
what does that mean action mode yeah
i'll tell you but i'll just say like in
crisis situations it's like the little
paper cuts of life on a daily basis that
make me lose my [ __ ] but like if there's
a if there's like a car accident or
someone is in the hospital or
something really bad happens
uh
i'm good in those circumstances right
like the freeze in austin and doing
disaster response and like i'm really
good in those circumstances so at what
action mode meant for me was number one
immediately scheduling a pcr test
to
definitively confirm that i was positive
but you you knew you'd taken like three
of these things no i taken i'd taken two
at that point but
before and actually this is important so
before considering different types of
actions or interventions
i wanted to
really
to the extent that i could be close to
100 certain be 100 certain
because
as you know one doctor i know well puts
it uh not peter another doctor he says
you know drugs
uh are all terrible with a few positive
side effects
meaning like you're you're signing up
for
a targeted effect that you're hoping
will be
helpful or beneficial but
almost all drugs have
known
and or unknown side effects it's just
it's just part and parcel very few
things are so selective that it's all
upside so i wanted to be as certain as
possible so pcr test and then as soon as
that was confirmed sort of
simultaneously scheduling because i
could cancel
let me just pause for a second and say
none of this is medical advice this is
very specific to me it's very specific
to conversations with my doctors but i
want to for educational purposes only
walk through this so that
people can if it's helpful
have some
view into my thought process
so i booked
uh iv monoclonal antibodies
which are from regeneron in this case
one question as this is unfolding where
you're at where you're based you were in
austin at the time is that correct
that's right
okay so is that something you can just
book i didn't even know you could just
like book or do you have to have a
doctor go and like
like how hard is it to get that
there is a company called drip hydration
drip hydration.com
and
my girlfriend booked the monocle
antibodies through drip hydration and
the way that works is
you effectively sign up
and then you will be and i'm probably
getting some of the details wrong here
but you will be contacted by
a doctor or nurse practitioner who does
an intake evaluation
because there are risks with with almost
anything
that is an in an unfamiliar
compound you can experience anaphylactic
response right you could you could have
anaphylactic shock you could die so
there are people who have
adverse events with monoclonal
antibodies and
as i'm also going into action mode i'm
talking to three different doctors
right and
it gives me tremendous sympathy every
time i have a situation like this or
some type of acute medical situation
how challenging it is to navigate
medicine and science even if you are
really plugged in so so i was in contact
i'm not going to name names so i was in
touch with three doctors
all very good doctors
one one effectively said
do monoclonal antibodies as quickly as
you can
because the sooner you do it the better
my understanding is generally you want
to administer within seven days of
contracting but keep in mind i don't
know when i contracted exactly it was
probably five days before i was
diagnosed
the second person said i don't think you
fit the risk profile you are
you are
you are not immune compromised from sort
of a textbook assessment
you're double vaxxed right you're double
vaccinated in my case with moderna there
are
possible downsides to
having the monoclonal antibodies
administered
i would say
i would advise against taking it and you
should wait and see
and if you develop more severe symptoms
then we can talk
the third doctor gave me the pros and
cons and this is a very common response
that you'll get gave me the pros and
cons and said really it's up to you
right i could justify
saying
go i could justify saying
don't go
that's a very challenging situation to
be in right because there is no
tiebreaker in this case
can i ask you how you got three doctors
are these like pre-existing doctors that
you've worked with in the past
pre-existing doctors okay i know you
know a lot of doctors i just like was
wondering like you're calling on people
randomly or
right 1-800 coveted doctors yeah
i am not calling at people randomly i as
you know kevin
really believe in
redundancy and backup yeah and
i have two backup whole house generators
at my house which meant i was one of two
houses in an entire neighborhood with
power during the austin freeze last
winter
you know my feeling and this is from the
military not that i was in the military
but a lot of my friends who have been in
the military will say two is one and one
is none like if you have two of
something you're gonna lose one of them
and then you'll have one if you have one
just consider it none right because
doctors get sick sometimes doctors are
unavailable
i'm not in a f in a near fatal car crash
right so it may not even qualify as an
emergency for some doctors
and for that reason i want to have
multiple people sort of on contract or
multiple people i've already done intake
with who i have relationships with who i
can contact via cell phone right that's
just if i'm gonna spend excess money
anywhere for redundancy
medical is where to spend it right for
you and your loved ones so that's how i
had three people
and i was doing this via email and also
via via cell phone and i spoke with all
of them and they're they're all great
but the point is there was no consensus
i ended up
for psychological reasons
deciding
that i wanted to do it because of my
some of my pre-existing conditions i did
not want to wonder
whether or not i was going to
develop
some type of respiratory distress or
collapse i just i didn't want to have
that on my mind for the next five days i
knew that if i had an anaphylactic
response i there there there are ways to
kind of attenuate that response with say
an epipen
or
uh intravenous uh i think it's
diphenhydramine benadryl
so there are ways to kind of mitigate
the risk so i decided to do monoclonal
antibodies and then
also decided with
through the advice of two out of three
doctors in this case
to take
fluvoxamine so i started taking
something called fluvoxamine
which
is a repurposed antidepressant this is a
very interesting case
so fluvoxamine and i'm reading here from
nature.com so i would expect it to be
credible and fact checked but obviously
do your own homework and please always
speak to any doctor before stopping or
starting any medications so common
antidepressants slashes risk of covid
death so fluvoxamine
not to be confused with proza with
prozac
which is i think
fluoxetine
has a very similar name but it's it's
different so fluvoxamine is is a
different antidepressant
that is cheap widely available and
frequently used for depression and
obsessive-compulsive disorder
so also i was like you know i'm kind of
curious to see what this will do to me
yeah win-win yeah yeah when but i'll
just read briefly so that people have an
idea of why this has been repurposed so
it is also known to dampen immune
responses and temper tissue damage and
researchers credit these properties with
its success in a recent trial among
study participants who took the drug as
directed and did so in the early stages
of the disease cova 19 related deaths
fell by roughly 90 and the need for
intensive covenant 19 related medical
care fell by roughly 65 percent
now
i i should however also read the quote
from a scientist at emory university
school of medicine in atlanta who says
uh
a a major victory for drug repurposing
but next quote fluvox mean treatment
should be adopted for those at high risk
for deterioration who are not vaccinated
or cannot receive monoclonal antibodies
so one could make the argument and one
of my doctors did make the argument that
a you're not at a high risk of
deterioration b you're vaccinated c
you're getting monopoly antibodies you
do not need to take fluboxamine so you
took the kitchen sink approach basically
i didn't though you didn't do the horsey
but you went almost horse i didn't do
the horsey
i didn't go full horse i chose two
interventions
and then i supplemented with vitamin d
and a handful of other
supplements that are very
low risk right i also supplemented with
baby aspirin for any type of like
thrombosis risk
and
so so one could make the argument that
this is complete overkill right but
for me in my mind as i'm tracking
outcomes and i've tracked this since
february
and i'm not
crazy i don't think i'm crazy like i
think i'm actually i think i would have
done the exact same thing by the way
based on everything that i've read i
think i would my protocol would have
been the same yeah you know i don't
think i've been crazy about this stuff
uh i think you know my paying attention
to this early allowed me to make some of
the best investment decisions of my life
so even if you think i'm a crank when it
comes to the science like understanding
the societal and supply chain
implications of this
uh is is useful
so that is what i did and
i'll just add a few things so what
happened right what happened
i ended up having
i would say overall
mild
symptoms
what was the text you sent me when you
said you woke up in the middle of the
night with a little bit of a panic what
was going on there with the chest stuff
so there were a number of kind of events
that were
very disconcerting so
but when people ask me like zero to ten
how bad was your covet and i was like
well people die from this so if dying is
ten like it's not
not a seven like i have to assume that
if it's like a seven or above you're in
the hospital so
four five perhaps i don't know
and
i did have so i had mild fever i had
severe severe headache
and uh very bizarrely like a localized
headache that felt kind of like an ice
pick in the side of the head
i hate those which was uh unpleasant i
had extreme muscle soreness to the
extent that it was hard to move at all
but the most disconcerting those are all
say severe
flu symptoms let's call it yeah it's the
lung [ __ ] that scares you though right
it was the respiratory distress and
labored breathing like tightness in the
chest and having difficulty breathing
that was the most
disconcerting for me by far and that was
just one night that was a few different
nights that was a few different nights
and
also
it's very difficult
to
determine causality what causes what
right because
so many things are happening
simultaneously so as an example
when i started to wean off of the ssris
because i've never been on ssris before
and
i also spoke to a number of doctors if
you were like you don't need to taper
off you can stop cold turkey because
only 10 days and then i spoke to a few
other psychiatrists who i trust very
deeply and they said absolutely don't
stop cold turkey and i tapered off so i
taper off of the ssris this is maybe
five days ago so let's just call it two
weeks post although i i took the
fluvoxamine at full dose for 10 days and
then tapered off at over say three or
four talk to your doctor don't just do
what i did
what i noticed was
each night as i started tapering off i
would wake up at between four or five in
the morning with a really rapid heart
rate and sweating profusely
crazy
now it happened once who knows what it's
from that can't be the ssri though
that's got to be just covered well hold
on so it could be anything right all
right it could be any number of things
but then it happened the next night and
then it happened the third night i'm
like okay something's happening but you
know is it from
covid
is it from
the ssris in in some capacity it could
be like there's a chance that that is it
it might be from the lack of ssris right
well that's the other thing like is it
because i'm experiencing a rebound
inflammatory response from removing
these ssris that have an
anti-inflammatory effect
i don't know
so i'm about now two and a half weeks
out i did my first workout last night
and
have had a splitting headache since uh
within a few minutes of starting
exercise my heart rate spiked to 150 160
beats per minute wow crazy one of the
most consistent high dude it was yeah
doing what doing nothing i mean getting
on a stationary bike for five minutes to
warm up wow
i will say the fatigue
and extended fatigue and ease of fatigue
has been the most
noticeable
persistent effect
and i remember also the the symptoms
coming in waves maybe at day five i
really was just going str so stir crazy
i wanted to go outside for a walk you
know mask on away from other people late
at night and
i ended up
going for my first walk not that night
but the next kind of late afternoon off
hours and i went for a
a walk in downtown austin
not near anybody way way out outside of
of any congestion
for a half hour
really slowly flat ground and i came
back and i was so tired that i fell
asleep for four hours
wow
yeah so
i'm
glad i took the precautions i did and i
will say this because and i've probably
lost people who are
you probably lost some people already
just listening to my recounting of this
but
the purpose of the vaccine
because i i saw a number of comments
when i put up
a notice just saying i've contracted
covid anyone who's waiting for anything
for me please just
be patient because it could be a few
weeks when i put up that note on social
people lost their minds
on every side in every direction it was
it's really disheartening to see
and it's not because i care personally
but it's it's
it's become such a divisive issue and
what i'll say just for me personally
i never expected
the vaccine to prevent me from becoming
infected
what i did hope for and based on the
data believed
was likely is that the vaccinations
would once i got covered
would reduce the risk of being
hospitalized or
having severe complications including
long-haul symptoms even if your initial
symptoms are mild
so
i just think that's really important to
say because a lot of the responses i saw
were oh you think you're so [ __ ]
smart like doesn't seem like your
vaccine is working and it's like well
guys
if if less than one percent and this is
the number i've been told by a number of
of docs so definitely check the primary
materials but if if less than one
percent of the people currently
hospitalized
are vaccinated
just based on the data forget about the
politicians forget about all the yelling
and screaming on youtube but just
looking at
the data we have which are not all
manufactured by big pharma
as someone who funds a lot of science i
just want to say like it's not that
simple right like the the conspiracies
on one side which are like all of this
is being driven by big pharma
have a grain of truth to them in the
sense that you know big pharma lobbies
and has a lot of capital and they they
they can exert influence but they don't
have complete control over something
like this
similarly you know on kind of
the other end of the spectrum you have
people who are concerned about nanny
states or police state
and the u.s government inflicting this
and forcing this upon people i'm not
talking about mandates by the way i'm
putting that aside that is just like
outside of the purview of this
conversation but if we're talking about
my personal reasons
i happen to still believe that good
scientists exist and that the scientific
method is the
the best
approach we currently have for asking
questions of nature and getting back
verifiable repeatable answers
and i was vaccinated to
keep the symptoms as mild as they happen
to be for me and i'm not convinced that
that would have been the case otherwise
yeah given that you know when things
were hitting new york i was on the phone
talking to doctors at mount sinai and
other places
senior attending physicians who are
telling me on the phone
if you hear people telling you that this
is just
affecting people who are 70 and 80 don't
believe them because
i'm looking in front of me at like two
or three
people in their 20s and 30s on
who are intubated and
they have no pre-existing
symptoms or co-morbidities none of them
smoke like you got to be careful with
this stuff
so
that is my story
you